[MUSIC PLAYING]
MEGAN SMITH: Hello, and welcome
to Women Techmakers.
This is a series that we
created for the Google
Developer Live channel to
highlight the extraordinary
women in our industry who are
making some of the amazing
products that we
all use today.
We are lucky to have Kim
Polese here with us.
And so just quickly, at Google,
I'm a vice president
at Google X. I've been here for
almost 10 years, worked on
lots of different things, led
new business development, did
lots of acquisitions, like
Google Earth and Maps and
Picasa, and love working
in technology.
PAVNI DIWANJI: And I'm
Pavni Diwanji.
I'm one of the engineering
directors on Google+.
And I'm really happy to be here
interviewing Kim, who I
worked with a long,
long time ago.
KIM POLESE: Exactly, yes.
MEGAN SMITH: Welcome, Kim.
KIM POLESE: Thank you.
MEGAN SMITH: That's really--
we're going to get into what
amazing things you're doing.
But that's really an amazing,
fun moment.
Because Kim, you're
the founding
product manager for Java.
KIM POLESE: Right.
MEGAN SMITH: That's amazing.
And you were in the Java team.
PAVNI DIWANJI: I was one
of the engineers
for the Java team.
MEGAN SMITH: You guys have
to tell us about that.
Like how did you--
tell us more.
KIM POLESE: Well, first
of all, it's so
great to see Pavni.
PAVNI DIWANJI: I know.
KIM POLESE: It's actually
been 15 years or so,
so here we are reunited.
It was an amazing, extraordinary
experience to be
on the Java team.
It was a very intense
experience.
We had some near-death
experiences along the way to
getting Java out to the world.
But it was incredibly,
incredibly rewarding, because
of the people on that team,
the most extraordinary
engineers, developers,
technologists that I've ever
worked with.
PAVNI DIWANJI: Kim, you have to
tell us the story of how it
was all born and how
Oak became Java.
KIM POLESE: Yes, it was-- it's
actually an amazing story.
A small team of some of Sun's
best software engineers wanted
to build a software system of
the future, for the future,
for a network world which
didn't yet exist.
And Steve Jobs was actually
trying to recruit them away to
come to Next to do that.
And basically Scott McNealy,
Bill Joy, and a handful of
Sun's executives, founders, said
stay, build it here, and
actually spun off a separate
company called First Person to
create this software environment
for this network
world that didn't yet exist.
I came on as the product
manager at this point.
So there was a technology,
but not yet a way to
bring out to the world.
And we made multiple attempts
at doing that.
PAVNI DIWANJI: There were
several misfires.
KIM POLESE: Exactly.
The Newton, which was the
state-of-the-art when it came
to mobile devices, Apple's
first attempt at the
smartphone or smart device.
There was the set-top
box market.
This was the early interactive
TV trials.
Set-top boxes were actually
SGI boxes that cost about
$20,000 apiece.
So none of this was ready
for prime time.
And we were really struggling,
trying to figure out how to
get this incredible,
extraordinary software out to
the world and make
it ubiquitous,
which was the goal.
It was ubiquity or go home.
And right at this critical
moment when it looked like we
were really failing at this,
Mosaic came along.
And so we realized, we could
create the world's first
interactive browser and actually
bring interactivity
and applications applets into
browsers versus just text,
static text.
And so that really opened the
floodgates to getting
developers to use
this technology.
We renamed it Java from Oak.
And then everything changed
in one day--
March 23, 1995.
PAVNI DIWANJI: How did
you convince--
I know you were one of the key
people who convinced that we
should put out Java free and
not bother to have any
constraints on it.
Because this is--
I think developers would like
to hear what prompted that
decision, what drove
that decision.
MEGAN SMITH: Because
that's a very--
PAVNI DIWANJI: That
was a key moment.
MEGAN SMITH: And it
was when things
like that didn't happen.
KIM POLESE: Yes.
That's true.
MEGAN SMITH: That's a very
normal thing now.
People like free, and then
there's some freemium.
There's some other way
that money comes.
But that's a really
extraordinary decision.
KIM POLESE: Right.
Giving it away free, publishing
the full spec,
everything open.
The fact that Bill Joy was
involved and was really part
of this from the beginning
was critical.
Because Bill really understood
the importance--
obviously with his background in
bringing UNIX to the world,
the importance of open systems
and open software.
So he, along with the
core members of the
team, went to Scott.
And it really didn't take a lot
of convincing just to get
them to say yes, because
they understood.
Sun came from that background.
The network is the computer,
open systems, UNIX.
So it was philosophically
aligned with Sun's roots.
But again, I just really give
a lot of credit to Scott
McNealy, Bill Joy, Andy
Bechtolsheim, the core
founders of Sun, who shepherded
this project along
even when things looked bleak,
and then took a risk and let
us give it away to the world.
PAVNI DIWANJI: I think this
might be a good lead to talk
to you little bit about your
journey and what prompted--
I was amazed when I learned
that here you are.
Java's really successful.
You are at the top
of the hill.
Then you decided to kind
of throw it all
away and do a start-up.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MEGAN SMITH: So she's ready
for her next thing.
PAVNI DIWANJI: Yeah, I'm like,
what kind of thought process
you went through?
What was your journey
like in terms of
entering the Marimba world?
KIM POLESE: It was actually
a very exciting moment.
It was sort of the birth of
the internet as we know it
today, the commercial
internet.
Netscape--
Mosaic Communications, it was
called at the time-- had just
been founded.
And we had just released Java.
And I started talking with a
few of my colleagues on the
Java team, specifically Arthur
van Hoff, Sami Shaio, and
Jonathan Payne, three of the
most extraordinary software
engineers on the planet.
And we started thinking about
what we could bring to the
internet now.
How could we take Java to the
next level and actually enable
businesses to build
enterprise-class applications
on this platform?
So more than just applets
and browsers.
And we realized we could build
a whole software system to
enable applications
to be remotely
distributed, updated, managed.
And that was really radical
stuff to go outside the
firewall and do that in a
disconnected use environment.
This was all very new.
So we got excited about
basically taking Java to the
next level.
It was also the fact that I
would have the opportunity to
work with these three
engineers who--
when you get the chance
to work with
extraordinary people.
And then on top of that, to
found and build a company.
I wanted to learn.
I wanted to learn
how to do that.
I wanted to just sort
of go out there.
And even if we crashed and
burned, we would learn a lot.
And I realized I couldn't learn
that anywhere else other
than just doing it.
So it was kind of the
combination of all those
things happening that made it
a no-brainer ultimately.
It was hard to leave Sun,
because I loved Sun.
I worked at Sun for
seven years.
I was so excited about Java
becoming now a key direction
for Sun and really shaping
a lot of the
strategy going forward.
But this was such a unique
opportunity.
And these three co-founders
were extraordinary.
MEGAN SMITH: It's an
interesting thing.
Sometimes people talk about,
when's the time to leave, per
se, and transition
to new things.
And I think one the best things
is when you're pulled.
KIM POLESE: That's true.
MEGAN SMITH: Not
feeling pushed.
Like maybe if you're in a bad
environment, you need to go.
But it's really like being drawn
with your passion into
the next thing.
Eric Schmidt always says life
is who you travel with.
So your point about the
colleagues that you had loved
working with that were so
extraordinary and being able
to go forward with them into
the next adventure--
KIM POLESE: So true.
MEGAN SMITH: --which was
actually building on the
adventure before, is
a great thing.
KIM POLESE: Exactly, yeah.
I find that it's really--
I think Eric's quote
is right on.
It's about who you
travel with.
MEGAN SMITH: So Marimba is right
in the middle of the
beginning of the web.
KIM POLESE: Right.
MEGAN SMITH: So I don't know.
I was running Planet Out at
that time, so it was an
extraordinary time.
Everybody knew each other, and
it was this whole thing with
going crazy.
Maybe it was the echo chamber,
maybe not, but it was--
people were on fire with it,
really passionate about what
was happening.
Early--
what year was Marimba?
KIM POLESE: January 1996
we founded the company.
MEGAN SMITH: Because in '96 and
'97, even into '98, people
were building and things
were starting, but it
still wasn't broad.
Like '99 is the Prince song.
It was this crazy year.
KIM POLESE: It reached
its peak of madness.
MEGAN SMITH: I actually know
somebody who took a photograph
of every person she
met that year.
And it's like got to be the
story of all these crazy
companies that existed and
parties, and there was so much
money because the
VCs were in big.
KIM POLESE: Exactly.
We went from being this
backwater of geeks here in the
Valley to suddenly being
the new Hollywood.
MEGAN SMITH: Right.
KIM POLESE: It was weird.
MEGAN SMITH: And then we sort
of went off a cliff.
PAVNI DIWANJI: Marimba, I
remember, it was the darling
of the press in that two-,
three-year period.
KIM POLESE: Yeah, there
weren't a lot of
start-ups at the time.
And here we were, four people
coming out of the Java team.
Woman CEO, so that was another
element to it.
So yeah, the few companies that
were out there got a lot
of attention, and we did, too.
PAVNI DIWANJI: Tell us a little
bit about your personal
journey, like jumping
off this--
being on the product management
train to then
taking on CEO and taking the
company from nothing to a
public company.
KIM POLESE: Yes.
Actually, being a product
manager was a fabulous
background to becoming
a founder and CEO.
Because as a product manager,
you have the total scope of
responsibility for taking this
lump of technology and making
it a success in the market.
MEGAN SMITH: At Google, we
almost think of it as mini
CEO, so it's funny
you said that.
KIM POLESE: That's exactly
right, exactly right.
So my time at Sun was the
foundation for learning on the
job to become a CEO.
And Sun was kind of
a sink-or-swim
environment, as you know.
PAVNI DIWANJI: Yes, I do.
KIM POLESE: You had to figure
stuff out on your own.
And that's what you have
to do as a CEO.
So the other part of this was,
it was important to me to have
the support of my co-founders
in being the CEO, and know
that I was the right CEO for
that point in the company, and
that I could mature along
as the company grew.
And so I always sort of kept in
mind how I was maturing as
the company grew as well.
Am I still the right CEO
for the company?
And I think that's an
important thing any
founder should do.
MEGAN SMITH: That's a
really interesting--
so I was talking with my friend
Mary Lou Jepsen recently.
And when we were actually-- this
was when we were all-- we
go to this great thing called
Silicon Valley Goes to the UK,
which Kim and I go to, where
we're talking to
entrepreneurs.
And Mary Lou drew this
triangle, this--
it's going to be
hard on camera.
I don't know if you guys can see
it-- but a small triangle
that said--
I think it was maybe the CEO
of Adobe who told her this.
When we're in--
she actually drew it up here.
She said when you're in a
start-up, you start small.
And then you imagine that it's
going to grow like this.
And so the people who start
the company are somehow in
charge of everybody forever.
But she just said that's
not what happens.
What happens is the start-up
people are
the start-up people.
And actually, if you think of it
more like-- this is kind of
a messy drawing.
But here's the triangle here.
This is the starting
group, and then the
company grows out.
And some of the team is
qualified or wants to go up
like an Amazon.
Jeff Bezos stays in the CEO, or
Larry and Sergey go up, and
different people.
And some people don't.
And some people actually love
the beginning, and they go to
the next thing.
It's sort of very interesting.
So as you were saying, here
you felt like, OK, I'm
qualified to get to
the beginning.
But then, am I learning enough
to keep staying in this
leadership state and
keep doing that?
And having also the trust
of your team is to
learn as you guys go.
KIM POLESE: Exactly.
And what I also realized along
the way is, well, most CEOs
have to do it.
Everyone has to be a first-time
CEO, right?
So everyone is figuring it out,
really, as they go along.
And that confidence thing
was a really important
breakthrough for me, realizing
wow, I can do this.
Everyone else is figuring
it out as they go, too.
So Jeff Bezos and Bill
Gates and everybody.
PAVNI DIWANJI: It would be great
if you talk a little bit
about the challenging or
the do-or-die moments
through this journey.
I'm sure there are
a bunch of them.
MEGAN SMITH: Like in the very
early days, you have some
funding, but you've got
to make payroll,
those kinds of things.
But also getting out there and
getting public, and some of
the challenges with that.
And then you guys eventually
were acquired, and some of
those faces, and then grew.
It continued to grow within.
KIM POLESE: Right.
MEGAN SMITH: And that stuff.
KIM POLESE: So early days, we
actually were getting a lot of
immediate offers for funding,
for venture funding.
We were getting calls from VCs
because we were so high
profile coming out
of the Java team.
And it was sort of all this
excitement about these start-ups.
We didn't want to take
funding, actually.
We wanted to build a product and
get some users, and then
once we had something we felt
confident we could take to
market, then go out and start
to talk to investors.
And that turned out to be a
really good thing, for a
variety of reasons.
For focus--
basically for nine months, the
four of us were in this little
tiny space that we rented.
And my three co-founders
were cranking away.
And I was building the business
plan and figuring out
how to take this technology and
make it into a product.
And those nine months were so
valuable because We built a
really strong product that today
is still the foundation
of this product line at BMC,
which was the acquirer.
My three co-founders
built an amazing
product during that time.
And as we know, the smaller
the team, oftentimes, the
better the code and
the product.
And we also were able to focus
on getting user feedback.
So we did that.
And then, once we went out and
got funding, of course, we
built value.
So we were able to retain more
equity in the company as the
four co-founders.
So then we were able
to go out and talk
to the venture community.
And Kleiner Perkins funded
the company.
We were part of the Java
fund, and we had great
investors in them.
So we had a wonderful
launching.
And then we were into
the madness of the
whole internet craze.
And one thing that I found
challenging was realizing that
what the outside world perceives
you do or are is not
necessarily true.
In other words, you can't
control, oftentimes,
perception.
Because here we were, this
enterprise software company,
and the outside world
wanted us to be a
dot-com consumer company.
MEGAN SMITH: That's the stuff
that's on the cover of--
KIM POLESE: Exactly.
That's the sexy stuff.
So there was this thing
called push.
There was a company called
PointCast, which was doing
something pretty revolutionary,
which was
sending, basically, broadcasts
of content, like sports
scores, weather, that kind of
thing, to your screensaver.
And this was on all the
screensavers of all the CEOs
all over the Valley.
And everyone was trying
to figure out
what this thing was.
Well, we kind of got lumped
into, oh, you must be a push
company, but we were
very different.
We were selling to Fortune
1,000, Fortune 500 companies
who wanted to deploy
enterprise-class applications
across the internet.
So that became really
challenging.
And I finally realized
at a certain point, I
can't control this.
All we can do is
really execute.
We've built a great product.
We have a great team.
We just have to build and
scale this thing.
And eventually, people will
realize what we do.
And that took longer than I
thought, that realizing part.
The building part didn't
actually take
longer than I thought.
It happened a lot faster because
there was so much
demand from business for this
software to run an internet
set of applications.
PAVNI DIWANJI: Did you have
challenges when you tried to
take what Marimba had produced
and tried to sell it in this
traditional enterprise?
How did they look at
you as a woman CEO
coming in from the Valley?
KIM POLESE: I'd never
thought about that.
You know how it is?
You just don't think about the
fact that you're a woman.
You're just doing your job.
One thing that actually worked
very well is, I hired the West
Coast Regional Sales
Manager for Tivoli.
Tivoli was an IBM company that
basically was the last century
version, or last-generation of
systems management software.
We were next-generation systems
management software.
So he knew how to sell against
our competitors, who were the
incumbents.
And so that allowed us to
get off the ground.
We went from $0 to $10 million
in the first year and kept
doubling revenue
year over year.
So we ended up burning very
little cash, ultimately using
very little of money we raised,
because we were
already successful out of the
gate, because there was a
market that we could
sell into as the
next-generation software.
So it actually worked
very well.
It's just the outside world
perceived that we were this
consumer company.
And then there was this whole
myth that developed around,
well, they were a consumer
company, but
they failed at that.
So then they had to totally
regroup and start all over
again, which was fine.
It doesn't matter what the world
thinks as long as you
know that you're building
something of quality, and
people are getting
value out of it.
And our customers were.
MEGAN SMITH: So a bunch of
different directions.
So maybe we should jump into, at
that same time, you started
to get very active--
or the Valley--
you're sort of tracked
as the internet came.
Here in Silicon Valley, we
started to engage with
Washington.
KIM POLESE: Yes.
MEGAN SMITH: We started to
understand that technology
policy was really important.
And a lot of it wasn't
being informed by
the industry creators.
And you were one of the
champions of doing that.
So can you talk a little bit
about those days at the time,
and what were the few
issues that really
kind of woke us up.
KIM POLESE: Yes, absolutely.
Yeah, I got a call from John
Doerr in '96, early '96.
Do you want to go
to Washington to
meet with Al Gore?
And this was right at the
beginning of the Valley's
engagement, as you
were saying, in
the political process.
What really tipped it off,
sort of instigated that
engagement in the mid '90s was
securities litigation.
There was a lot of basically
frivolous lawsuit
filings going on.
Basically every company in
the Valley was being
hit by these lawsuits.
And so we realized, we have
to be at the table.
If you're not at the table,
you're on the menu, and that's
basically what was happening.
And so there was a much broader
set of issues beyond
securities litigation.
So that included getting
broadband network deployed,
figuring out encryption, policy
around encryption,
ultimately later privacy.
And it's not always fun engaging
in the sort of
down-and-dirty political process
of negotiating and--
PAVNI DIWANJI: But
it's necessary.
KIM POLESE: --and
compromising, but it's necessary.
And it's actually really
interesting stuff when you get
to the policy side because you
can craft policies that really
drive growth, economic growth.
And policymakers--
senators, members of Congress--
have 1,000
different issues they're dealing
with, and they don't
always know stuff you
assume they know.
So you have to be there having
that conversation.
And it just takes continual
presence and engagement.
And I actually have
grown to love it.
MEGAN SMITH: And you've
done a fair amount.
So you guys went out and you
met with Gore, with Vice
President Gore at the time.
And then was TechNet
existing yet?
Or was--
KIM POLESE: It was really
at the founding
moment in the 90s.
John Chambers, John Doerr,
small group,
got it off the ground.
MEGAN SMITH: And they're
still going strong.
KIM POLESE: Very much, yeah.
MEGAN SMITH: And are you still
involved with them?
KIM POLESE: Yes, yes.
I'm on the executive council.
And it's a unique organization
in that it's direct CEO
engagement, a lot of policy
organizations, or advocacy
organizations, or government
affairs folks who are critical
as part of the process,
but not CEOs.
And this organization is very
much the CEOs engaged in the
conversation at the table.
MEGAN SMITH: Very cool.
I think we have a screenshot
of TechNet.
Yes, no, maybe?
We could kind of show quickly
just so people see it.
But--
KIM POLESE: This whole SOPA,
PIPA, for example--
MEGAN SMITH: Was one of the
most recent issues.
But I think it's so important
to not only have the
conversation, but also have an
organization like TechNet
where we can be a resource
to policymakers--
KIM POLESE: Right, exactly.
MEGAN SMITH: --and available
to them.
KIM POLESE: And bipartisan,
nonpartisan.
The point is to move the
conversation along and figure
out solutions rather than
getting stuck in these
polarized political
dog fights.
MEGAN SMITH: Right.
Thanks for your work there.
KIM POLESE: Happy to serve.
MEGAN SMITH: We need you.
PAVNI DIWANJI: Do you want
to-- maybe we can talk a
little bit more on Marimba and
how you kind of maneuvered the
public waters and how the
company got acquired.
I think a lot of entrepreneurs
in the audience or who are
viewing would like to
know, like, when do
you make the decision?
Do you keep going, or do you
just say, that's it, the price
is right, or the
time is right?
MEGAN SMITH: And also an
interesting thing, having
worked on lots of acquisitions
at Google, it's our incredible
engineers like Pavni and others
have invented a lot of
stuff here.
But actually, probably, if you
look at our portfolio of
products, I don't know if it's
half, but a very large number
of them were made by people
who invented them here,
including Larry and Sergey in
the beginning with search, and
then a lot of stuff through
incredible acquisitions where
teams came in and then
built from there.
And it was really great
to hear that
BMC is going forward.
So they're sort of like--
the point of we're building this
thing, but is it actually
better leverage at some point
to jump in with someone else
and then build even bigger?
I think in some ways the Keyhole
team always talks
about that with Google Earth,
like, what we were able to
achieve together was something
that neither of us would have
been able to do apart.
KIM POLESE: Right, right.
It's always a difficult decision
about whether and
when to sell.
For us, we were from the
beginning a successful
enterprise software company.
We were able to get to
profitability, actually,
shortly after we went public,
which was quite
unusual at the time.
MEGAN SMITH: Which was
certainly incredibly
revolutionary at the time People
would say, we're a
pre-revenue company.
And you're like, well, what's
your revenue plan?
They're like, well,
I don't know.
We'll figure it out later.
KIM POLESE: We were going around
$50 million in revenue
at the time.
MEGAN SMITH: Wow.
KIM POLESE: And basically
the bubble burst.
And there was this very weird
period, which, now I've lived
through a couple--
several cycles.
But at this time, it was
basically a lot of Sandhill
Road, frankly.
Conventional wisdom was saying
enterprise software is dead.
Search is dead.
Advertising is dead.
It was-- everyone went mad.
MEGAN SMITH: I used to joke that
they were saying this is
dead, but they were
doing it on email.
[LAUGHTER]
MEGAN SMITH: The internet's
dead.
We're all clicking,
surfing around.
It was that we were sort of way
out ahead of ourselves in
a lot of ways.
But actually, what's so
interesting, having been in
those moments, is they play
out at some point.
Maybe in a different form, but
many of the ideas happen.
KIM POLESE: Exactly.
So the entrepreneurs and the
founders and the developers,
of course, weren't paying
attention to all those
pronouncements.
They were just getting down to
the work of building software
and continuing to build
the company, which is
what we were doing.
So we had a lot of customers who
were really depending on
the software for a lot of their
foundational internet
business apps.
We didn't really miss a beat.
What happened was the world
around us went crazy, and our
stock price plummeted.
And at one point, the stock was
worth less than the cash
we had in the bank.
We had $60 million in the bank,
and the stock was worth
like $42 million.
And we had no debt.
So that was how crazy
things had gone.
But basically, we
hung in there.
And that's a lesson that I've
learned again and again, is
persistence, not giving up, even
when everyone around you
saying, you're crazy,
give it up.
PAVNI DIWANJI: I think it's
a necessary gene for
entrepreneurs.
KIM POLESE: Absolutely.
PAVNI DIWANJI: Or else
you do not survive.
KIM POLESE: Yes.
MEGAN SMITH: Encourage.
You now, somebody announces
something that's exactly what
you're doing.
You're like, oh no, but then
time plays out, and you go
into competition.
It's like, it's fine.
KIM POLESE: Things work out.
MEGAN SMITH: Staying
at the table.
KIM POLESE: Yeah, as long as
you know you're building
something of value that
the world needs,
just keep doing it.
So that's what we kept doing.
And so eventually, the
market recovered.
Our stock price recovered.
We had started a relationship
already with BMC, a
partnership.
It turned out that they were
really a very good fit for us
in terms of distribution
channel, a way to get a lot
more volume in the market.
So the acquisition turned
out very well,
I think, for everybody.
And in fact, the core team--
there was a core team that
remained, in fact.
Several employees are still at
BMC, as far as I know, one of
whom became the CTO of BMC.
So it ended up being a
great acquisition,
I think, for them.
MEGAN SMITH: In both
directions.
KIM POLESE: In both
MEGAN SMITH: That's good.
PAVNI DIWANJI: So after that,
I'm sure you had a choice,
like, having taken a company
from nothing to a successful
public company.
So what made you plunge
into the start-up
world all over again?
You wanted to do it
all over again?
KIM POLESE: I guess I'm
officially a serial
entrepreneur.
I confess.
I just love founding and
building companies.
I love being on a mission
with smart people out
to change the world.
I mean, I think there's just
nothing more exhilarating
professionally or in
life in general.
And so this was SpikeSource.
It was the next company I did.
This was an open source company
that was focused
basically on helping businesses
and people use open
source software much
more easily.
So we were automating the
management of open source
stacks, application stacks.
And the open source business
was an interesting one as a
market, a challenging one, and
particularly during the
economic times, ultimately,
that we all lived through.
But the company that we built
was very powerful.
And ultimately now, we're seeing
all around us, this
automation of open source
software and stack management.
We were a cloud company, of
course, before people were
talking about cloud
and all of that.
And this has been kind of a
persistent theme for me.
I started my career, actually,
in artificial intelligence and
expert systems software back
when that was hot.
And then it sort of went
through its cycles.
And now, of course, AI
is everywhere, but no
one calls it AI.
We get excited about things.
We get ahead of ourselves.
But we, as entrepreneurs and
founders, keep building.
And eventually, the
world needs it.
And so that's what happened
with SpikeSource.
I just love that process.
PAVNI DIWANJI: A lot of the
audience today is going to be
developers primarily.
So maybe you can spend a little
bit of time on your
learnings around open source
software and developer
community, like your tenure
at SpikeSource.
KIM POLESE: Yes.
Well, one of the things that I
just find so rewarding and
exciting is the fact that open
source has really unleashed
this army of software
developers globally.
And back when I was growing up
in the software world at Sun,
working for Eric Schmidt,
actually, who was running a
software product division at
that time, software systems
were closed.
And it was very difficult to
get access to software.
It was expensive.
And everything changed when
the internet came along.
We've seen such an incredible
explosion of creativity.
The developers were the ones
that really made Java
successful.
They built the applets.
There wasn't any kind of
marketing campaign.
There was no marketing
campaign.
It was the developers
who did it.
And it's the developers who
are changing the world.
And open source is really
enabling that.
So I'm thrilled, as a software
geek from way back, to see
what's happened.
MEGAN SMITH: It's
sort of the--
like Wikipedia, the creativity
kind of opens up.
KIM POLESE: Yeah.
MEGAN SMITH: I was lucky to
work with General Magic
really, really early on.
And Andy Rubin was there,
who's the Android lead.
And we were working
on, whatever,
these little devices.
But they were this big.
One time the Motorola CEO
sent us an actual
brick in the mail.
[LAUGHTER]
MEGAN SMITH: But we were even
before open source.
So we thought that we needed an
alliance, very much in an
'80s model, the way that Apple
or Microsoft and developer
communities--
but it was much more
controlled.
KIM POLESE: Very much so.
MEGAN SMITH: And then Andy, of
course, went on to do Danger
and Sidekick.
And I think in that case,
he also faced--
these are getting smaller.
And Sidekick was awesome.
But still, the closed nature of
the way that the carriers
were treating the app
store equivalent.
Like it was in their version
in their way.
You had to talk to them.
They would bless it.
Maybe they would brand it.
Much tighter controlled network
side, so even the
devices were trying
to open up.
And so in some ways, I think
Android is his-- it's their
time to watch the movie, and
to act in the movie, and to
drive that and sort of--
KIM POLESE: It's cool.
MEGAN SMITH: It's cool to see
how open source in all forms
and what he learned and what you
learned came full circle
to really allow for the surface
area of the world's
creativity to act in concert--
KIM POLESE: Exactly.
MEGAN SMITH: --with
open standards.
It's an amazing innovation.
In a lot of ways, I think the
21st century is very much
about openness.
KIM POLESE: Absolutely.
MEGAN SMITH: And it's
interesting with your
government work in that as we
see government transparency
come forward, or even
lightweight things in the
early '90s where open source
comes, so does truth and
reconciliation in South Africa
as South Africa transitions,
and this idea of openness
and more.
KIM POLESE: Right.
MEGAN SMITH: It's an
extraordinary thing.
KIM POLESE: It is.
It's changing the world in
amazingly profound ways.
And what's great is being able
to participate in that, both
in big companies and
also start-ups.
Software developers are
changing the world.
That's basically the
bottom line.
MEGAN SMITH: And those
who team up.
Let's talk about ClearStreet,
because that's a real change
idea, which is incredibly
exciting.
And I think maybe borne out of
the ideas of Occupy Wall
Street and unfairness and
how do we help people--
say more about what you're
thinking with that.
KIM POLESE: So I think everyone
knows, there's a huge
problem with debt.
And in fact, something like 43%
of American households are
90 days away from being
in poverty,
from going off a cliff.
People just don't
have savings.
And now the credit card debt
is a trillion, a massive,
massive problem people
are facing.
And the solutions today--
payday lenders, just the kind
of options that exist are
really bad.
So we started looking at
the power of social.
How could we use the power of
people helping each other both
on the savings side and also on
the buying everyday items
side to build assets and
to get out of debt?
And we started looking at
something called rotational
credit, which has existed
for centuries.
It's very prevalent all over
the world, particularly in
immigrant communities or in
under-banked communities,
where people don't have access
to traditional banks.
And small groups of people
agreeing to get together, say,
once a week or once
a month save a
certain amount of money.
And then once a week, if they're
doing it on a weekly
basis, one person goes home with
all of the contributions
from that week.
And so it's a way of getting
access to lump sums of cash.
And the social contract that
exists between people, kind of
Weight Watchers style, when
people know they've got some
pressure from their friends
to follow through on their
commitment, they do.
MEGAN SMITH: Professor Eunice
did some of that with
microloans around each person
getting a loan and having
support from each other, and a
little pressure, a little peer
pressure to help you
get through that.
KIM POLESE: Yeah.
So its that kind of
foundational idea.
And we're taking that.
We're putting basically a social
and mobile later on
that, so it's easy to start
your own savings circle.
And then we're accelerating it
with merchant-funded rewards
earned from everyday spending.
So it's kind of this idea of
loyalty, building merchant
loyalty and earning rewards
savings, which go directly
into your savings circle.
Earn $1 off that item.
That $1 goes in your savings
circle rather than
disappearing in your pocket.
MEGAN SMITH: Is this--
is that--
KIM POLESE: So that's
the basic idea.
And it's based on stuff that's
been proven to work, this idea
of saving circle or
rotational credit.
Matched savings--
so we're basically taking the
merchant reward and creating,
essentially, a form of
matched savings.
So that kind of acceleration of
one's own savings habits.
And then prize link savings is
another thing that's been
proven to work.
People, if they know that
there's an incentive, like to
win an iPad or something like
that, they will adopt good
behavior or better behavior, for
example, take a financial
literacy quiz, or adhere to a
savings goal or what have you,
based on an incentive like
a prize, winning a prize.
So we're taking these kind of
concepts around behavioral
economics that have actually
been proven to work in
practice and putting technology
around it and
creating a solution.
The focus is on helping people
get faster access to cash so
they can pay off debts and then
build long-term savings.
And there's a whole movement
across this country right now
around asset building.
And there's also a whole new
generation of entrepreneurs
who are building new kind of
financial services companies
that are about making profits
and creating a success
financially and also ensuring
that people get ahead
financially instead of getting
further and further in debt.
MEGAN SMITH: Using our tools to
help make a difference in
this area, because it's
hitting everyone.
KIM POLESE: Right.
PAVNI DIWANJI: And maybe you
can talk a little bit about
what's next for ClearStreet.
Are you planning to do
internationally, go
international?
Are you just going to
be focused locally?
KIM POLESE: So we're starting
some small pilots locally
here, but ultimately, this is
something that works globally.
And it's a solution that's
ubiquitously used today in an
analog world.
And so our goal is ultimately
to have this be a global
solution and product service.
MEGAN SMITH: They're
giving us a signal.
We've got a little
bit more time.
I wanted to know about your
dancing a little bit.
You're an amazing dancer.
Say a little bit.
PAVNI DIWANJI: I think a better
way to ask the question
is, how do you balance--
[LAUGHTER]
KIM POLESE: I grew up dancing.
I grew up here in
the Bay Area.
I discovered ballet
when I was 14.
I just never stopped dancing.
And it's always kept me sane.
What's great about dance, any
form of dance, is that it
takes total focus.
You can't just zone out and run
on a stationary or cycle a
stationary bike.
You have to actually be
memorizing choreography.
You have to be thinking about
every movement of your body,
and position the arms,
and so forth.
And it's also incredibly
physically demanding.
It kicks your butt.
And so that's been
this wonderful--
really literally-- balance in my
life, and a counterpoint to
a very intense professional
life.
And for me, what I've realized
is that everyone needs
something that they're
passionate about outside of
what you do every day,
especially if you're in a very
intense work environment.
And dance has been
that for me.
MEGAN SMITH: It's interesting,
just because getting--
doing exercise--
and most of the tech
companies have
workout places, et cetera.
But to think about that a little
bit differently, as you
have, which is take something
that you've been passionate
about as a young person and are
exceptionally great at,
because I know your dancing,
and to keep that going as a
parallel track for the classic
like, let me go run on the
treadmill, which is also good.
But it's a really different
way of approaching it.
KIM POLESE: Yes.
MEGAN SMITH: I just thought it
was a very interesting thing.
PAVNI DIWANJI: I have
one question in the
same train of thought.
What advice do you have for
young women out there?
I saw your Forbes rebuttal
and loved it--
bashing through the
stereotypes--
and you standing up while
everyone was watching.
So what advice would you give to
our young women developers
who are either entering tech
or have just entered tech?
KIM POLESE: Go for it.
You're better than you
think you are.
And the opportunities
are just infinite--
the opportunity to found a
company, to build a company,
to lead a project, to
change the world.
And we need more women
technologists and women in
general, women leaders
doing that.
MEGAN SMITH: Kim and I were
just in England for the
Silicon Valley Comes
to the UK.
And we were at Bletchley Park,
which is-- and we have these
books, which is the amazing
place where they cracked the
Enigma codes during
World War II.
And what was so interesting to
learn about this extraordinary
place and the work that was
done-- and really the founding
of the modern computer
industry was there.
Alan Turing was there--
was that it was half women
and half men, and such an
amazingly diverse group.
KIM POLESE: Exactly.
MEGAN SMITH: And so
we were lucky to
meet some of the veterans.
And they were totally
passionate, women and men in
their nineties.
KIM POLESE: Yes.
MEGAN SMITH: Awesome.
KIM POLESE: So inspirational.
MEGAN SMITH: And I think
sometimes people don't realize
the kinds of teams we're in.
They think somebody's coding
all alone or something.
But it's really--
the tech industry is amazing.
We hope that more people, young
men and young women,
will join us.
KIM POLESE: Yeah, absolutely.
In fact, you're right.
I think people don't realize how
social it is, the process
of creating and building
technology.
It's very much about teams and
interactions of teams.
And the importance of diversity
in really bringing
all different views and
approaches is so critical and
often overlooked.
And it's actually one of things
I love about Google is
that you guys have really
prioritized
that from the beginning.
And Bletchley Park is definitely
worth a visit if
you're ever in the UK.
MEGAN SMITH: 45 minutes of
train ride from London.
Last question--
heroes.
KIM POLESE: Heroes.
I would have to say my mom.
I had an amazing mom.
She grew up in a farm
in Denmark.
World War II, the Nazis occupied
the farm, and kind of
a very interesting beginning.
And she just decided to leave
the farm, go travel the world,
never went back.
She was the only one of
her family not to.
She had this attitude of--
she was so positive and very
realistic about life, but also
that perspective of never
give up-- persistence.
Keep at it.
And she did against various
obstacles along the way, and
she never lost her positive
attitude.
And she was also incredibly
social person, very generous.
Anyway, I'd have to see
my mom, hands down.
MEGAN SMITH: Awesome.
Thanks, Kim, for being here.
KIM POLESE: My pleasure.
MEGAN SMITH: Thanks to everybody
who joined us.
And congrats on ClearStreet.
I think it's really
significant in
your amazing history.
Thanks for sharing with us.
KIM POLESE: Thank you.
It's really an honor
to be here.
Thank you both.
PAVNI DIWANJI: It's
great to catch up.
MEGAN SMITH: Yeah.
KIM POLESE: Exactly.
MEGAN SMITH: Reunite, reunite.
That's awesome.
[MUSIC PLAYING]